[Música]
Gracias por compartir este momento con
nosotros en France 24 Gracias
el año pasado usted se convirtió en el
primer escritor de la África
subsahariana galardonado con el premio
literario francés más prestigioso el
premio Goku por la más recóndita memoria
de los hombres un año después que balón
se puede hacer de esta experiencia
no sé si hay que hacer un balance Porque
todavía estamos en ello en realidad las
cosas no se limitan al año en que lo
recibimos Obviamente el primer año
Tenemos muchos encuentros
descubrimientos ferias festivales firmas
pero tras eso casi un año y medio
después empezamos a salir al extranjero
que es por lo que estoy aquí en México
porque luego llega el momento de las
traducciones alias
de traducción y traducción Así que sigo
acompañando los libros es una aventura
extraordinaria de encuentros y también
de conocimiento de uno mismo porque
después de haber pasado tanto tiempo
escribiendo solo de repente uno se ve
frente al mundo con el poder que genera
el premio con kuro como gran galardón
literario
también es un gran cuestionamiento sobre
la forma en que escribimos y de cómo nos
leen ya que nos encontramos con un gran
número de lectores llega a ser bastante
vertiginoso también es muy agotador
física y mentalmente no hay que ocultar
esto porque ves muy poco a tu familia y
amigos y apenas estás en casa pero todo
eso se redime con otros encuentros en
cualquier caso estoy muy contento de
estar en esta gira
y justamente es lo que le iba a
preguntar esta experiencia fuera de lo
común que le ha llevado hasta México
para la feria del libro de Guadalajara
le ha hecho sentirse más cerca de las
reflexiones que expone a este libro
sobre la soledad que a veces
experimentan los artistas en su camino y
sobre el poder de la literatura y de
ciertas obras
en cierto modo el libro sigue
escribiéndose ya que uno de los temas es
precisamente lo que un libro hace al
lector y lo que el escritor en medio de
todo esto intenta encontrar su lugar
esto es exactamente lo que estoy
experimentando desde hace un año y medio
observéo Sí ya que ahora me paso la vida
mirando observando y escuchando lo que
la más recóndita memoria de los hombres
ha producido y ha creado en otros
lectores
también tratando de encontrar el punto
justo entre las emociones de los
lectores y mi propia mirada simplemente
como autor ya que no quiero interferir
demasiado en lo que los lectores leen y
sienten Por supuesto Siempre hay una
forma de soledad pero la más evidente es
durante la escritura después de escribir
te acercas un poco más a los lectores y
en cierto modo es muy bueno es algo que
me gusta y me alegra mucho ver cómo el
propio libro se enriquece siempre
transformado por los lectores que lo
reciben
esta novela La más recóndita Memorial de
los hombres recibe su título de una
frase en un libro del escritor chileno
Roberto bolaño Los detectives salvajes
cuéntenos Cómo llegó este artista a su
vida
Y aquel que por amigos hace unos años
estaba en Francia estudiando todavía y
tenía dos amigos que una noche estaban
hablando del libro de un autor
misterioso al que yo no conocía del que
nunca había oído hablar ni de él ni de
su obra y era Roberto bolaño
anotar me dijeron que tenía que leerlo
Porque si había que leer a un autor
sudamericano contemporáneo importante
era él así que seguí inmediatamente ese
consejo y en los meses posteriores a
aquella noche no hice otra cosa que le
era bolaño leer todo lo que pude
encontrar de él y amarlo true y
m bolañó
[Música]
encontrándome completamente abrumado
transformado intrigado y cuestionado por
esta obra que es de una calidad
literaria extraordinaria y de una gran
potencia en lo que dice sobre la
literatura sobre el mundo sobre la
relación con la literatura sobre la
búsqueda del sentido de la literatura
pero también sobre la relación entre
literatura y vida sobre la relación
entre literatura y política y sobre lo
que significa ser escritor Y ser lector
y es un autor que fue realmente decisivo
en la escritura de mi novela también de
manera general en mi forma de leer
simplemente
el otro paralelismo que surge entre su
obra y América Latina son los círculos
de escritores su héroe gigante
desarrolla en París entre un grupo de
jóvenes escritores africanos al igual
que escritores como Pablo Neruda Mario
Vargas llosa fue deliberado hacer este
paralelismo
Entonces se quería pero no Por esa razón
si deseaba porque yo mismo vivía en
círculos de escritores tenía círculos de
amigos escritores con los que en París y
en otros lugares como senegal también
pasábamos mucho tiempo hablando de
literatura leyendo libros comentando los
juntos debatiendo y a veces
enzarzándonos en peleas muy épicas y que
te complete
teníamos una vida completamente
estructurada por la lectura de libros y
por la escritura por el sueño de
escribir por las dudas que compartíamos
por las esperanzas que nos unían y por
una gran amistad cuyo fundamento Era
realmente la literatura pero en el fondo
creo que muchos lugares y en todas las
épocas los escritores también se han
encontrado en estas situaciones hablando
entre ellos en una especie de
marginalidad pero al mismo tiempo
estando en el corazón de la sociedad
para encontrar una manera mejor de dar
forma a su arte y a sus intuiciones y
básicamente Eso es lo que me pasó a mí
cuando miras a América Latina ves a
todos estos escritores que se han
estructurado en movimientos que se han
estructurado en torno a revistas la
revista Sur por ejemplo en América
Latina ha sido importantísima
casi se tiene la impresión de que será
escritor corresponde a una nacionalidad
que la literatura es un país que reúne a
los artistas es algo que siente muy bien
sean particularidad
sí es una idea que me gusta
especialmente que siento esto no
significa que los escritores no tengan
una nacionalidad estoy en buena posición
para saber que los escritores tienen una
nacionalidad lo que significa también un
cierto número de limitaciones o ventajas
ligadas a esa nacionalidad pero la
literatura es simplemente el país que
uno inventa para sí mismo el país que
uno elige para sí mismo que no tiene
fronteras reales o en todo caso donde
las fronteras son porosas y solo piden
ceder bajo la curiosidad bajo el deseo
de encontrar Ecos amistades semejanzas
en otros espacios culturales Esta es
realmente Mi idea de la literatura la de
una gran biblioteca abierta Por lo que
todos los escritores Y también todos los
lectores pueden Navegar libremente la
literatura biblioteca
en mi libro hay un pasaje dedicado a
esta cuestión de la literatura como país
y el personaje que se interroga en ese
momento dice que elige el país fatal
antes que el país natal y el país fatal
es el país de la biblioteca en el fondo
sí un escritor siempre tiene dos
nacionalidades la suya propia pero
también la que le forma la literatura y
los libros que ama los libros a los que
está ligado en una forma de genealogía
el libro que el libro que él informes
[Música]
y hablando de nacionalidad de la
procedencia de estos escritores el
segundo personaje central de su libro El
escritor Maldito el imán Le escribió una
vida que va del continente africano al
europeo y luego a Buenos Aires a América
Latina habría conocido a los más grandes
desde las hermanas Ocampo hasta Borges
Por qué hacerle ir a América Latina en
lugar de volver a África como el
escritor en el que se inspira en
maliense Jambo que ganó el premio
genundó En 1968 por deber de violencia y
que fue luego acusado de plagio y cayó
en desgracia y desapareció por debajo
hay una justificación totalmente
novelística es decir en la novela
descubrimos La razón por la que se va a
latinoamérica yo dejo a los lectores que
descubran esta línea de la trama pero
también hay una razón más política Si se
quiere o más literaria las dos están
ligadas aquí
emoción
prioritaria
se trata simplemente de dar como decía
antes una especie de idea de biblioteca
más abierta y ya no marcada simplemente
por el cara a cara o por movimientos
binarios o lo uno o lo otro en este caso
se trataba de decir que no se trata
simplemente de formar parte de una
relación de adversidad entre África y
Europa sino que también Había otro
continente que estaba ahí a partir del
cual una escritora africano también
podía reinventarse o encontrar Ecos así
que me gustó la idea de hacer dialogar
estos tres continentes me gustó la idea
de hacer pasar a el inam entre estos
tres continentes porque es ahí donde le
lleva su búsqueda su investigación
porque busca algo o a alguien pero su
búsqueda personal su búsqueda
existencial y al final después de haber
pasado por esos continentes encuentra
otra forma de apaciguamiento y ahí
también dejo que los lectores descubran
cuales
leía una de sus entrevistas en la que
hablaba del aspecto paradójico de elegir
escribir en francés porque es solo una
pequeña parte de la población senegalesa
puede leerle que se siente al pensar que
un año después del premio concurt con lo
que nos estaba contando que ahora llegó
el momento de las traducciones Y que
ahora este libro está entre las manos de
personas que no hablan francés tampoco
pero en este caso aquí hablan español
Cómo se siente de pensar que un día
seguramente le habrán leído más
latinoamericanos que senegaleses
Latinoamérica
Me parece muy bonito Sencillamente me
parece muy bonito porque aquí
evidentemente las lenguas son
importantes y las traducciones también
pero yo simplemente veo los lectores
cuando un libro te llega a través de una
traducción cuando lo lees te olvidas de
que es una traducción porque te
comportas como un lector este fue mi
caso
latinoamérica leí por ejemplo a Bolaños
a escritores latinoamericanos a través
de traducciones y creo que cuando los
leí obviamente me vi simplemente como un
lector después hay un elemento bastante
interesante que es ver como un lector
sudamericano recibe este libro que viene
de un africano pero que también trata un
tema sobre América Latina y su historia
esto es muy interesante y es lo que
estoy encontrando en este momento con
los lectores que ya han leído la
traducción de la más recóndita memoria
de los hombres español después para los
lectores de senegal Es cierto que
escribir en francés significa aislarme
de la mayoría de ellos bueno de gran
parte de ellos pero también confío en el
tiempo y quizás en posibles traducciones
Grand Party me refiero si confiamos
traducción posible traducciones aquí una
palabra genérica para Designar la manera
en que un libro pasa también a una
cultura a formas que no son solo las del
texto no son solo las de la lectura sino
que pueden pasar al teatro que pueden
pasar al cine que pueden pasar a la
poesía popular que pueden pasar a otras
formas el audiolibro por ejemplo en
otras formas que evitan el encuentro
cara a cara que a veces puede ser un
poco abrumador un poco paralizante un
poco impresionante con un libro Eso es
todo pero me alegro de que las
traducciones permitan ampliar la
comunidad de los lectores Eso es todo
Muchas gracias Nuevamente gracias a
usted
[Música]